hola valentina bueno pues estos fármacos
son una gran noticia son los primeros
antivirales que tenemos de vía de
administración oral recordemos que kobe
19 es una enfermedad en que la primera
etapa es la viral y la segunda es la
inflamatoria y no teníamos un
medicamento de administración oral sino
nada más intravenoso que era el recibir
los anticuerpos monoclonales que también
son intravenosos entonces esta propuesta
de merck y de facer es extraordinaria
porque es una forma en que podemos
ayudar a los pacientes desde casa cuando
inician los síntomas y funcionan
interrumpiendo la replicación del virus
haciendo que el virus no pueda
multiplicarse dentro de nuestras células
es llamativo que este anuncio the
fighter se produzca sólo un día después
del de merca se puede hablar de que
vendrá algo así como una lucha de poder
entre las farmacéuticas por desarrollar
cada vez más rápido medicamentos contra
el cob y 19 y esto podría ser inseguro
de alguna forma
bueno por supuesto que si fuera el caso
nos beneficiaría porque obviamente
aceleraría el poder tener fármacos
exitosos fármacos eficaces para poder
ayudarnos a combatir esta esta
enfermedad pero bueno ambos comenzaron
los estudios en julio y en agosto los
resultados que dio merck los dio hace
hace aproximadamente tres semanas y
ahora gran bretaña ya dio por primera
vez la autorización de uso de emergencia
del mono pira beer de merck pero fisher
ya había dado un preliminar hace unas
semanas de su fase 2 y 3 y lo que pasa
ahora es que parece que por una
recomendación de un comité de monitoreo
de información en consulta con la sda
decidieron interrumpir y ya dar a
conocer estos resultados por su éxito
tan rotundo 89 por ciento de disminución
de riesgo eso es tan importante que
entonces ya la farmacéutica pfiezer va a
pedir la autorización de uso de
emergencia para finales de mes a la sda
a finales de noviembre mientras que
invertía pidió la autorización para uso
de emergencia entonces bueno van muy
pegaditos lo vimos similar con las
vacunas y ahora estamos entrando en la
los medicamentos orales para ayudarnos a
resolver kobe 19 en las personas ya con
diagnóstico positivo bueno brevemente
los resultados de estos fármacos como
usted ya lo mencionado han sido han sido
considerados una nueva esperanza en la
lucha contra el virus cómo se logra que
el bolo para vivir el pacs luiz y
futuros desarrollos médicos no sean
contraproducentes porque se podría
malinterpretar con que prevengan el
contagio de kobe
quizás la mejor forma de verlo valentina
es verlo como tenemos el caso de la
influenza en que por un lado tenemos la
vacuna tan importante de influenza
porque nos ayuda a prevenir los casos a
minimizar la circulación del virus y
hacer que los casos sean más leves lo
mismo nuestra vacuna contra kobe 19 y
por el otro lado es importante tener
tratamientos para las personas que aún
cuidándose se pueden contagiar entonces
es muy importante la labor que hacen
ustedes y todos los medios de
comunicación en precisamente comunicar
esta diferencia porque requerimos ambos
frentes la prevención a través de la
vacunación pero también los tratamientos
para apoyar a los médicos y apoyar estas
personas que si se contagian después de
consucode 19no con señora ambas son
importantes y lo vemos con la influenza
igualmente discúlpeme señora perelmán a
usted muchísimas gracias por compartir
este análisis en france 24